hey this story involving Ryan Lochte and
other American Olympians in Rio in
Brazil is really getting weird we first
reported that Ryan Lochte in some other
swimmers were robbed in Rio we then
learned that it appears as though they
actually made it up or at least there is
now the suspicion that they made the
entire thing up and a Brazilian judge
actually ordered police to seize the
passports of Lochte and some other of
Olympians including gold medalist James
Fagin so that they could be questioned
because the descriptions of the robbery
had now are not adding up supposedly it
took place in the early hours of Sunday
morning and it included some other
Olympians including gunner benson jack
conger the brazilian police stopped at
least two Olympic swimmers from boarding
a flight home just a couple of days ago
to question them but uh Ryan Lochte for
example was already back in the United
States passports were seized
inconsistencies in the stories they've
asked the taxi driver that supposedly
was involved in the evening to come
forward with the taxi driver hasn't some
people say that's because there is no
such taxi driver others are saying that
it's because the taxi driver doesn't
want to get involved because uh they
just but you don't want to get involved
they want nothing to do with this thing
whatsoever up this is just a very very
strange story and there's speculation as
to what may have happened here I don't
it if it does turn out that the robbery
was made up I truly don't get why
anybody would make that up other than to
try to hurt Rios image because a lot of
the athletes are very displeased with
how Brazil has been set up in terms of
the facilities and the water quality and
so many other things but I really don't
get it uh yeah I don't get it either I
could see them be at Brazil and the
authorities being very upset with the
story being made up because there cuz so
concerned about their image yeah uh but
there is so much to criticize and they
failed in so many ways this entire
Olympics that there's really nothing to
salvage in terms of their image uh and I
I just don't get why they would really
care if this story was made up when when
countless tourists uh will tell you the
exact same story well it does get more
attention
right when it's in when it's ryan lochte
who got robbed then it's when some tools
would even if it wins a thousand tours
because as we know you know a million
people being victimizes is a statistic
one person being victimized is a tragedy
or whatever the case may be any thoughts
on the inconsistencies of the stories
you know kind of loses point you know I
think this was potentially or 11 story
that I heard was that this is a chance
for them to kind of get out of going on
a night of partying and then coming home
and not you know being on time for
practice next day or saying like that
and just an easy way to scapegoat Brazil
and get out of it when you know who's
who's great at this point lock to your
Brazil probably in most people's mind
Lochte so you're saying sort of a way to
cover a night of drinking that uh may
have been actually what precipitated
whatever took place the next day in
terms of them being late uh maybe that
this was a cover for that uh it's also
possible that the stories are different
from each of the each of the individuals
because they were drinking I mean is
that we're just completely speculating
here yeah i mean i'm sure that's
definitely playing into why no one is on
the same page here if you have any
thoughts as to what the hell is going on
is Donald Trump likes to say uh please
let me know i'm on twitter at d pakman
i've talked about how people of all ages
but particularly millennials are owning
cars less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars suvs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at join
zipcar dot-com slash david